على قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه او
الكسندر ساسكي ان الجيش الاوكراني انهك
قواته في مدينه
روسيا لاشراك القوات المحموله جوا في
الهجوم عليها اضافه ان الوضع في ضخمه صعب
لكنه تحت السيطره واشار الى ان روسيا
تحاول تنفيذ ما تعرف بتكتيكات الارض
المحروقه في باخموت على غرار ما فعلته في
سوريا وفق قوله هيئه الاركان العامه
الاوكرانيه افادت ايضا بصد قواتها اكثر من
اربعين هجوما في اتجاه كل من باخموت
واليمن
ومارينكا وارسال محاوله تقدم الروسيه
باتجاه بلده رمادا الواقعه شمال غرب اخوه
وفي المقابل الاعلان المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تكبير الجانب الاوكراني
خسائر في منطقه جراز نيليمند الى جانب
تدمير طائره اوكرانيه مسيره فوق المنطقه
بدورها قالت وكاله
قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه اطلقت اكثر من
100 مقذوف في محور دونيتس خلال الساعه
الماضيه
لروسيا ان القصف الاوكرانيه استهدف في
اليومين خلال اليوم الماضي من مناطق سكنيه
مختلفه ما اسفر عن اصابات بين مدنيين
واضرار في بعض المباني السكنيه
الامن الغربي ضخمه مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود ومن دونيسك مراسل الجزيره بابا ولد
حرمه ارحب بكم ابدا معك بابا وولد حرمه
حول القصف الذي تعرضت له
والانباء الوارده حيث انت
نعم سلطه المحليه هنا تتحدث عن توجيه
القوات الاوكرانيه اكثر من مئه مقرف على
منطقه
خلال الاربعين ساعه الماضيه طبعا كانت
السلطات المحليه قد اعلنت امس تعرض احياء
سكنيه ومدنيه في هذه المدينه في مدينه
لقصف
قالت انه خلف اضرارا بالمباني واكثر من
ذلك خلف اصابات في صفوفي
المدنيين طبعا القوات او الجيش وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تتحدث كذلك عن توجيه ضربات
وتكبيد الجيش الاوكراني خسائر في هذه
المنطقه في منطقه بالعشرات بل وبالمئات
كذلك على طول خط الجبهه بين الطرفين
الروسي
والاوكراني المواقع العسكريه روسيا وفي
مقدمتها موقع ريبار تتحدث عن هذا الهجوم
الوشي الهجوم المرتقب هجومي الربيع الذي
تعد له اوكرانيا على الاراضي التي تسيطر
عليها القوات روسيا وتقول ان هذا الهجوم
قد يبدا في غضون اسبوع او اسبوعين تقول
هذه كذلك تقول هذه المواقع ويقول موقع
ريبار بالتحديد ان المسيرات ستكون لها
المسيرات سيكون لها دور محوري في بدايته
هذا الهجوم وان اوكرانيا ستستهدف خلال
بدايه هذه الهجوم منشات عسكريه ومدنيه في
عمق الاراضي الروسيه من اجل تشتيت جهود
القوات الروسيه طبعا هذا او احتمال
استخدام المسيرات المسيرات في هذا
الهجوميه الاوكراني يؤخذ هنا على محمل
الجد تتحدث وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن اسقاط
المسيرات يوميا بالامس تحدثت عن اسقاطه
سبع مسيرات وقالت كذلك قلم العسكري الروسي
انه منذ بدء الهجوم اسقطت القوات الروسيا
اكثر من مسيره اكثر من 100 مسيره برقدار
خلال
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه المواقع العسكريه
تتحدث كذلك عن استخدام هذه المسيرات في
رصد المواقع العسكريه ومن ثم استخدام
صواريخ هايمرز وكذلك المسيرات الانتحاريه
وقال موقع ريبار ان المسيرات كان لها دور
في هذا الهجوم الذي حدث قبل يومين في
جزيره شبه جزيره القرم على ساحلها الشرقي
حيث استهدفت حيث استهدف صاروخ هناك هذه
هذه المنطقه وقالت القوات الروسيه انها
تصدت له واسقطت دون ان يخلف اي اضرار
بشريه او ماديه في هذه المنطقه البعيده
نسبيا وقالت هذه المواقع الروسيه كذلك له
من المحتمل ان يكون هذا الصاروخ قد اطلق
من بعيد من على بعد من منظومه للصواريخ
تقع على بعد اكثر من اربع مئه كيلو متر من
المنطقه من الساحل الشرقي لشبه جزيره
القرم وزاره الدفاع الروسيا تتحدث كذلك عن
تك
على طول الجبهه تقول انها استهدفت في
منطقته في محور
جنوب دنيتك استهدفت مخزنه للوقود كان يضم
اكثر من 70 الف طن من الوقود كانت تستخدمه
القوات الروسيا المقاتله على جبهه الدنيا
جنوب
ايضا مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود طبعا بخمت
ما زالت جبهه مشتعله حسان لكن هنالك حديث
متواتر اوكرانيا الان كذلك عن القرم وما
يجري فيها وما سيجري فيها
[ضحك]
نعم زين نبدا من هنا من بخمه حيث كان قائد
القوات البريه الجنرال قد زار هذه المدينه
مجددا اليوم بعد اعلان القوات البريه انه
قام بهذه الزياره لاكثر المناطق سخونه في
الجبهه وفق تعبير بيان القوات البريه ومن
هناك كان قد اكد ان الاوضاع في داخل ضخمه
صعبه للغايه لكنها مازالت تحت السيطره وفق
قوله وكذلك اعتبر ما يجري في بخموت هو
اشبه بالارض المحروقه المحروقه هذه
السياسه التي تعتمدها روسيا الان في بخموت
وهو شبهها بما حدث في سوريا سابقا وفق ما
قال خلال تصريحاته وخلال زيارته هناك هذا
ايضا اتى بعد تاكيده ان القوات الاوكرانيه
ق الحاق خسائر كبيره بقوات فاجنرما دفع
القوات الروسيه لطلب تعزيزات من قوات
المظليين القوات المحموله جوا وكذلك من
قوات مهاجمه من الجيش النظامي الروسي واكد
ان كل هؤلاء ايضا يتكبدون خسائر كبيره هذه
معارك المستمره هناك في باخمه التي وصفها
بالشرسه ايضا تدور في محيط منطقه باخمت
نحن نقف هنا عند الطريق الواصل الى باخ مت
عبر البلدات الداخليه وهذا الطريق هو الذي
يشهد معارك مستمره تحاول القوات الروسيه
الوصول الى هذا الطريق تحديدا الى المنطقه
القريبه منه من بخموت لقطعه وقطع طريق
الامداد الطريق يستمر بتقديم الامدادات
والدعم للقوات المقاتله في بخمه ويتواصل
عليه القصف اليوم هيئه الاركان قالت ان
القوات الاوكرانيه صد هجمه باتجاه بلده
خروموفو الواقعه نهايه هذا الطريق
وهناك كانت القوات
الروسيه تحاول ان تصل الى هذه البلده لكن
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها افشلت هذه
الهجامات هذا المشهد متكرر ايضا في افيفكا
جنوب مقاطعه او المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه منها وكذلك شمالا في
ليمن حيث ايضا كانت القوات الروسيه حاولت
التقدم هناك والقوات الاوكرانيه لذلك وفق
بيان هيئه الاركان هذا هنا في المنطقه
الشرقيه اما اذا تحدثنا عن القرم وما يحدث
هناك فكان هناك عدد من التصريحات التي
تشير من قبل المسؤولين الاوكرانيين ان
القوات الروسيه بدات بالاستعداد للانسحاب
والتوجه الى المنطقه الروسيه من شبه جزيره
القرم وكان هناك عدد من التصريحات حول ذلك
ولكن هذا الامر ما زال وفق وتحت الدراسه
والمتابعه شكرا لك من غرب فخمه حسان مسعود
شكرا ايضا
لبابا حرمه كان معنا من دونيتسك